A few weeks ago I was asking you about Resveratrol, you mentioned that it has a very short half-life,
so it takes smaller doses throughout the day. I was wondering if that holds true for the
fermented Resveratrol from Premier Research Lab. It's the same. Yes, so Premier Research Lab has
kind of one of their things and a lot of their supplements are they are fermented in batch doses.
I've actually toured their facility down in Austin, Texas, where they make these things quite interesting.
And they have fermented Resveratrol. I have a lot of you people on the fermented tumeric.
I think it adds to its benefits to the body. I think it adds to its accessibility as far as
absorbability. So I think they're great products, but it doesn't shorten their half-life.
So you'll still, the half-life is just how fast your body breaks down the end product in your
tissues and in the blood. So it still has a very short half-life, so you still want to
break it up through the day. And that's really goes through, goes for all of your supplements.
The more you can split up your doses, let's say you're supposed to take three a day of something,
and you take them all in the morning, that might not be the best way to dose things
for most supplements. Now it's different with your fat-soluble vitamins, and it's different if you're
trying to get up to a certain dose of vitamin C so that you have the antioxidant effects of the
vitamin C. So vitamin D, you could take that all at once. You don't need to split that up. That'll
store it in your body. That vitamin A will store it in your body. Vitamin E will store it in your
body, but a lot of your herbs, they're going to have a half-life. A lot of all your bio-flavanoids are
going to have a half-life that aren't, that isn't real long. So by splitting it up, you're going to give
your body a better benefit in how you deal with that and how it helps you.